[Applaudissements]
l'extrait est ce que vous trouvez que
c'est une bonne idée ou pas franchement
super idée les frais je pense qu'elle
sera très rigolote et je pense que ça
sera l'embellie pourrait ce qu elle
s'enfermait dans des émissions de bruit
sur nrj dos ça va être un second souffle
pour elle en plus c'est une grande
journaliste en allait de belles enfin
franchement elle et elle n'a pas sa
langue dans sa poche
après faudra savoir c'est là
suffisamment d'autodérision ce qu on
morfle eu pas mal d scarso faut savoir
supporter quand même qu'on se moque de
nous et ses jolies filles parfois c'est
moins facile de traverser une grande
gueule en plus donc elle va elle va
balancer c'est ce qu'on va dire donc
elle va balancer elle va aller bien pour
l'émission droit que les gens ne la
connaissent pas très bien mon avis un
étendard et qu'on dirait tout personnage
colin farrell donc je ne fais pas du
tout à quoi m'attendre dans ses
réactions au sérieux son parc non mais
enfin parce qu'elle coûtera très bonne
démarche est absolument fan d'erika
moulet depuis le tout début et je pense
que c'est une très bonne recrue d'accord
avant qu'elle arrive qu'ils veulent à
pécho dans l'équipe pour savoir merci
jean michel mercier très bien comme ça
[Applaudissements]